pour participer à cette table ronde même
si je l'ai lieux ne sont pas tout à fait
ceux d'une table ronde donc on va
commencer parce que à la suite de votre
audition on a les deux ministres madame
panier renacher et Monsieur Béchu et
donc on peut pas se permettre de prendre
trop de retard et le président de la
FNAIM nous rejoindra en cours d'audition
donc nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui nos travaux par
une table ronde je l'ai dit autour des
acteurs de l'immobilier sur la
rénovation du parc privé et des
copropriétés donc nous recevons 9
acteurs du secteur de l'immobilier
l'Union nationale de la propriété
immobilière l'une pie une association
qui assure la défense des intérêts des
propriétaires privés qui représentées
ici par Monsieur Alexis Lagarde
président de l'une pie des Pays de la
Loire
la Fédération nationale de l'immobilier
la fnaïm qui regroupe les professionnels
de l'immobilier qui est représentée à
ces semences sous peu par Monsieur Loïc
Cantin président et qui devrait être
accompagné par son chef de cabinet
madame Bénédicte roux l'association plus
rien qui regroupe des professionnels de
l'immobilier représentés par monsieur
Étienne de kerese président ah ben voilà
je parlais de la ah non non et par
Monsieur Pierre authus délégué général
l'association Unis qui regroupe les
professionnels de l'immobilier
représentés par Monsieur Pierre
non
représenté par Monsieur Olivier Safar
président adjoint de l'UNIS et président
de l'UNIS Grand Paris l'Association
nationale des gestionnaires de
copropriété qui représente les intérêts
des gestionnaires des comptables et des
assistants de copropriété représentées
par son Président Monsieur Gilles
Frémont le réseau d'agences immobilières
en franchise Guy Hoquet l'Immobilier
représenté par Madame Delphine Hermann
directrice des relations extérieures
l'entreprise de gestion immobilière
Foncia ADB représenté par Madame
Laurence battle présidente le groupe
Nexity représenté par mesdames Karine
Olivier directrice du pôle service aux
particuliers et Florence Rognard
responsable des affaires publiques et
enfin la Fédération des promoteurs
immobiliers de France la FPI France
représentée par Monsieur Pierre vital
président de la FPI nouvelle Aquitaine
et de la commission FPI France
réhabilitation extension rénovation par
Monsieur Franck ovorka directeur
technique et innovation et par Madame
Anne pericaud directrice des relations
institutionnelles voilà Mesdames
Messieurs vous représentez la diversité
des métiers de l'immobilier en tant que
représentant d'agences immobilières de
promoteurs ou d'administrateurs de bien
alors que nous arrivons pratiquement au
terme de nos auditions de notre
commission d'enquête qui nous ont
occupés depuis la fin du mois de janvier
sur la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments il nous est naturellement par
une nécessaire d'associer bien sûr les
acteurs de la filière de l'immobilier
qui participe à la rénovation
énergétique des logements
vous allez sûrement l'évoquer dans vos
interventions liminaires les uns les
autres les politiques publiques
d'accélération de la rénovation
énergétique sont d'abord pour votre
secteur génératrice de contraintes et
nous en sommes pleinement conscients ici
au Sénat j'aimerais ainsi vous entendre
sur des conséquences sur le marché de
l'immobilier du calendrier mise en place
et tel qu'il a été voté de la loi climat
et résilience de 2021 qui prévoit une
interdiction progressive des passoires
énergétiques mais dans y aller
relativement court j'aimerais également
connaître votre regard sur d'éventuelles
nouvelles obligations qui pourraient
peser sur le secteur immobilier certains
acteurs proposent par exemple une
obligation de rénovation lors de la
vente de bien le marché de l'immobilier
est-il en mesure de faire face à de
nouvelles contraintes de ce type cette
audition doit également nous permettre
au delà des en spécifique au marché de
l'immobilier d'identifier les freins
spécifiques à la rénovation énergétique
des logements en copropriété
l'Observatoire national de la rénovation
énergétique que nous avons auditionné à
évoquer un retard des logements
collectifs dans la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments mais nous
pouvons nous aussi directement sur nos
territoires pouvoir quand même le
constater et cela malgré les dispositifs
d'aide spécifiques existants ma prime
rénov copropriété
écope TZ copropriété
quels sont selon vous les freins
spécifiques à ces rénovations et surtout
comment peut-on accélérer la rénovation
énergétique des copropriétés alors que
pour atteindre les objectifs ambitieux
fixés au plan national une accélération
paraît indispensable enfin hier soir la
première ministre a conclu le Conseil
national de la refondation sur le
logement annon notamment le renforcement
de ma prime rénove pour atteindre 200
000 rénovations performantes en 2024 le
déploiement des guichets France rénov et
de mon accompagnateur Renov d'ici 2025
ne parle que des mesures qui ont été
annoncées concernant la rénovation
énergétique mais sur le reste on est
tout et tous on a tous été quand même
assez surpris par les annonces qui ont
été faites hier estimez-vous ces
propositions suffisantes au regard de
celles formulées par le groupe sur la
transition écologique dans le logement
avant de vous laisser la parole pour
répondre déjà à ses premières questions
et pour des propos introductifs dans
l'ordre que vous souhaiterez faire il me
revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'un compte-rendu sera publié mais il
m'en revient également de vous rappeler
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission d'enquête est passible des
peines prévues aux articles de 434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 € d'amende c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous invite tour à tour à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité à lever la main
droite et à dire je le jure après ce
formalisme mais qui est obligatoire dans
le cas d'une commission d'enquête et
bien vous prendrez la parole pour un
propos liminaire l'aisant et les autres
et ensuite monsieur le rapporteur et les
membres collègues qui sont donc ici
présent et qui assiste à cette audition
pourront également bien sûr vous poser
un certain nombre de questions monsieur
la garde si vous voulez bien on commence
par vous
et bien je vous remercie je vous laisse
la parole alors si vous ne voyez pas
d'inconvénient on va peut-être commencer
par vous et puis dérouler dans l'ordre
voilà dans lequel vous êtes assis autour
de cette table si vous le voulez bien
monsieur Lagarde
merci de me donner à la parole j'ai vu
qu'il y avait
merci
[Rires]
de me donner la parole j'ai regardé
quelques commissions déroulées donc il y
aura des répétitions j'imagine
ce qui nous apporte nous c'est le DPE en
fait quand on est malade on s'inquiète
de voir un thermomètre qui donne des
températures différentes suivant le
médecin qui vient et ça c'est très
inquiétant alors chez nous nous
adhérents en fait ont un problème de
confiance la confiance est rompue c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui une ça pue quoi
faire
il part au plus pressé c'est éviter les
interdictions et encore c'est aussi
retirer du marché un certain nombre de
d'appartements de maison
c'est
moi j'ai retenu dans le la Commission au
patrimoine et aussi la commission ADEME
que la priorité c'était quand même de
faire une rénovation globale on est
complètement à côté de la plaque on le
voit des gens nous contactent pour faire
un minima j'ai beau leur expliquer dans
les assemblées générales et des réunions
comment il faut procéder il faut viser
au minimum le C pour être tranquille
pendant un certain temps mais ça on ne
fait que repousser quand même le dépe
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt c'est à
dire que on va rénover pour après
retourner encore à nouveau rénové le
même logement pourquoi parce qu'on
n'aura pas fait la totalité et je j'ai
oublié de préciser je suis dans le
bâtiment depuis 40 ans
Marseille je sais pas si c'est ça mais
on peut pas évoquer ce genre de choses
mais pour les bâties plus récents c'est
vrai qu'on peut travailler d'une manière
plus efficace dans tant qu'on n'est pas
dans les périmètres de sauvegarde donc
nous on n'est pas du tout opposé à la
mise en place de ça mais de manière
intelligente et pragmatique on a évoqué
ça lors de nos réunion avec les
ministères c'est des sujets que tout le
monde connaît
je vais peut-être pas prendre plus de
parole alors pour moi la confiance et ça
passe aussi par le législatif et aussi
la fiscalité parce que là il y a une
instabilité vous savez bien comment sont
les Français
voilà bon je laisse la parole je
reprendrai peut-être tout à l'heure mais
je voudrais pas monopoliser la parole je
vous remercie
je vous remercie d'abord
alors Florian se représente comme
d'autres associations qui sont présentes
en particulier les syndics de
copropriété et syndic de copropriété
c'est une profession réglementée comme
vous le savez donc et nous sommes au
cœur de la gestion des copropriétés par
définition que ce soit la gestion
administrative la gestion sécuritaire et
bien sûr tout ce qui concerne la
rénovation rénovation des différentes
installations de l'immeuble jusqu'à la
rénovation énergétique donc d'abord je
vous remercie de nous avoir invités
parce que dans les propos notamment qui
ont été donnés dans les journées
précédentes voir celle d'hier le mot
syndic n'est jamais sorti ce qui est un
peu gênant parce que je pense que une
rénovation énergétique du monde de la
copropriété sans les syndics c'est une
rénovation qui sera très très difficile
et très longue
sur les sujets nous qui nous importe
beaucoup nous sommes tous acteurs nous
syndiquent de la rénovation et nous la
voulons il y a aucune résistance dans la
profession pour dire que nous sommes
contre la rénovation ça n'est pas un
sujet nous sommes plutôt dans une
vision très pragmatique de comment donc
vous l'avez très bien évoqué et le
commence ces trois points essentiels le
premier c'est le financement je pense
que mes collègues vont revenir sur le
sujet donc là je laisserai la parole et
reviendrait si besoin donc le
financement de cette rénovation et
notamment le financement bancaire qui
est le plus gros sujet pour moi vous
avez un deuxième sujet qui est un tout
petit peu technique mais quoique qui est
cette dichotomie diagnostic individuelle
et je vais dire diagnostic collectif
plus exactement DPE collectif pour les
puristes mais on va voilà où la
rénovation est considérée vous l'avez
dit comme une rénovation efficace il y a
les globale et la loi impose un
diagnostic individuel opposable donc là
on n'est pas tout à fait sur les mêmes
terra ins de jeux ce qui pose beaucoup
beaucoup de difficultés et puis le
troisième là c'est un peu plus classique
c'est le nombre de subventions puisque
moi j'en dénombre 14 qui viennent
s'empiler alors faut se louer qu'elles
existent il faut rappeler qu'elles
peuvent contribuer jusqu'à 30-35% du
coût de la rénovation donc ça faut se
féliciter qu'elles existent mais il y a
forcément des choses à imaginer pour
qu'elle soit plus efficiente et pratique
aux pratiques voilà
bon pour le Nice donc moi je suis donc
Olivier Safar je suis en même temps
parce que je dois vous déclarer l'ancien
membre du conseil d'administration de
Lana puisque j'étais remplacé dans ces
fonctions par Loïc Quentin président de
la finale début d'année et membre du CNR
logement sur la partie rénovation
énergétique vous avez bien compris que
ce que l'on a entendu hier nous a
fortement déçu et je suis poli ça ne
correspond pas du tout à ce que nous
avons travaillé mis en place écrit
réécrit et on avait même proposé de
rajouter un complément sur cette partie
rénovation énergétique pour faire la
distinction de maison individuelle d'un
côté et copropriété de l'autre côté pour
une fois on avait une vision qui allait
dans le bon sens simplement vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui le calendrier est
complètement inadapté en copropriété ou
en gestion locative nous sommes bloqués
par des impératifs d'agenda qui ne sont
pas les bons comme propriété en moyenne
pour arriver à faire des travaux et on
est tous volontaires que ce soit les
covoritaires les syndics mais aussi des
entreprises c'est globalement entre 3 et
5 ans c'est à dire que ça rentre dans la
tête d'une de copropriété ça avance on
fait une analyse on présente les choses
à une première assemblée générale on va
à une deuxième assemblée générale pour
le voter on obtient les subventions
l'année suivante avec les financements
s'il y en a et derrière on fait les
travaux donc en moyenne vous êtes parti
sur quatre ans ou 5 ans ça c'est le
premier point aujourd'hui on est
inadapté en copropriété parce qu'il faut
respecter ce calendrier le deuxième
inertation de calendrier c'est par
rapport au DPE individuel quand vous
êtes propriétaire bailleur et là vous
retrouvez dans des complications qui
sont violentes on se retrouve dans
certaines assemblées générales avec une
opposition entre covorite occupants et
co-boritaire bailleur pourquoi parce que
l'occupant lui il a rien à faire le
bailleur il est coincé par ces dates
2023 2025 et on va dire le plus
rapidement possible mais sans faire la
partie complète de la covoyéité ou de
l'immeuble on y arrivera pas
deuxième point c'est le fléchage des
aides je vous cache pas que à l'origine
quand on a demandé des aides à Lana pour
aller sur ma prime rénov copro et ma
prime rénov globale j'avais demandé à ce
que l'on flèche le montant qui est
attribué d'un côté aux maisons
individuelle et de l'autre côté au
propriétaire cette disposition n'avait
pas été reprise par Bercy et ils avaient
dit à les départs on démarre avec 800
millions d'euros débrouillez-vous
l'année suivante on a demandé beaucoup
plus parce que l'utilisation a été faite
en maison individuelle à 99% pour vous
tout vous dire ma prime rénov copro la
première année il y avait même pas 100
dossiers de déposer sur 550 000
syndicats de copropriété voilà où on en
était
et dernier point c'est le guichet
guichet unique pour toutes ces aides et
Étienne de quirès a raison lui il en a
démembré 14 j'en ai dénombré un peu plus
j'en suis un peu près à 19 pourquoi
parce qu'il y a certaines aides
complémentaires de certaines communes de
groupements de communes certaines aides
de certains quartiers avec des opaques
complémentaires le dernier point c'est
le financement de tous ces points là
j'ai demandé suite à la lettre de
mission qui a été faite par Monsieur le
Ministre du Logement donc Olivier Klein
qui a fait une lettre de mission à la
Caisse des dépôts et à la banque des
territoires la création de la Banque de
la rénovation énergétique cette demande
au départ n'avait pas été entendue pour
pas dire autre chose c'était on était
début janvier la Caisse des dépôts et la
banque de finance la banque des
territoires a repris contact on leur a
expliqué qu'aujourd'hui il ne s'agissait
pas que de copropriété il s'agissait
bien évidemment de copropriété mais
aussi de propriétaires bailleurs mais
aussi de copropriété tertiaires et aussi
de certains logements sociaux qui
avaient du mal à financer à trouver les
financements pour y arriver donc c'était
une vraie banque de la rénovation
énergétique elle n'a pas besoin d'avoir
des agences dans toute la France elle a
besoin simplement d'être créé comme la
banque de finance des territoires tout
simplement c'est ce point-là est une
difficulté et surtout on a dit que si on
veut faire tout ça il faut une loi de
programmation de 5 ans renouvelables
cinq ans si vous n'arrivez pas à valider
les choses pour que les covriers les
propriétaires les locataires comprennent
qu'on est sur de la stabilité on
arrivera à rien ça change tous les ans
tous les six mois tous les trois ans
c'est trop et je vous cache pas
qu'aujourd'hui Alana les dernières
modifications on va arriver sur un
système qui va être pillé performance
pilier efficacité c'est les derniers
points que l'on a en cours ça sera
annoncé probablement le 12 juin prochain
mais clairement on augmente les montants
mais c'est trop de changement c'est trop
compliqué pour tout le monde et derrière
les dossiers à remplir quand vous avez
un dossier une fois deux fois trois fois
à la cinquième fois vous le remplissez
plus parce que c'est tout en ligne à
chaque fois sur chacun des portails
voilà
merci beaucoup donc monsieur Frémont au
nom de l'Association nationale des
gestionnaires de copropriétés bien merci
aujourd'hui je représente les
gestionnaires donc du terrain syndique
de copropriété également nous avons
observé
copropriété 4 freins qui peuvent devenir
quatre leviers s'ils sont inversés
rapidement le premier frein et comme mes
confrères le soulignaient la fluctuation
des lois les lois changeantes nous
depuis 2014 nous avons eu l'oie allure
loin Macron loi Elan loi climat et
résilience loi 3DS que depuis 2014 sans
compter la valence de décret et
d'arrêter
nous avons comme outil le PPP le PPP le
DTG l'Audi énergétique l'audit
architectural le DP individuel le DPE
collectif le DTG plus plus de l'agence
parisienne du climat je travaille à
Paris subventionné qui au passage
gonfle les prix des prestataires et nous
avons aussi les PPP des prestataires qui
rajoutent commercialement certaines
offres ces lois changeantes créer deux
choses un de l'attentisme chez les
copropriétaires il n'est pas rare
d'entendre en assemblée générale les
copropriétaires nous dire d'ici à ce que
ça change autant attendre il est urgent
d'attendre ça c'est ce qu'on entend et
le deuxième la deuxième conséquence
c'est une formation constamment en
décalage des professionnels des
praticiens des gestionnaires de
copropriétés qui n'ont à peine le temps
de se former que la loi a déjà changé le
deuxième frein c'est l'épargne l'épargne
en copropriété qui est un suivi
insuffisante Lana a révélé que le
montant moyen du Fonds travaux qui
existent depuis la loi allure
quatrième frein pardon la fiscalité et
les aides publiques on a clairement un
manque de visibilité un manque
d'incitation nous avions observé que
l'ancien crédit d'impôt transition
énergétique le site paraît aux
copropriétaires puisque c'était quelque
chose de concret et d'immédiat
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur ma prime
rénove c'est quelque chose peut-être
d'un peu plus abstrait un peu plus
lointain un peu plus aléatoire
manque de visibilité on a énormément de
guichets multiples d'ailleurs un guichet
unique il est fait pour être unique si
on a plusieurs guichets c'est plus un
guichet unique c'est ce sont des
guichets multiples aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas si notre interlocuteur et l'APC
ou Lana par exemple
et on a un manque de visibilité sur la
durée puisqu'on ne sait pas si dans
quatre ou cinq ans lorsque les travaux
seront réalisés ma prime rénov sera
toujours existante
la TVA nous avons observé également une
progression la TVA puis 20 ans à
l'époque elle était à 5,5% sur
l'ensemble des travaux elle est passée à
7 et très rapidement à 10%, ça a
clairement enchérit le coup des travaux
je vous remercie merci beaucoup le
réseau des agences immobilières en
franchise Guy Hoquet madame Hermann
merci bien la présidente
tout d'abord je voudrais
[Musique]
comment dire confirmer ce qu'il y a déjà
été dit par un de nos confrères le la
rénovation énergétique la transition
environnementale des logements fait
consensus au sein des professionnels de
l'immobilier et nous cherchons tous à
trouver des solutions pour avancer
concrètement vers la réduction
significative de l'impact
environnemental du logement
en tant que professionnel agent
immobilier nous pouvons être un
baromètre pour les pouvoirs publics de
ce qui se passe sur le terrain pour
remonter des informations sur le les
besoins les aspirations et les
inquiétudes des Français en matière de
logement et de rénovation énergétique
donc merci de nous donner la parole
notre rôle c'est d'être un facilitateur
clairement pour les Français donc nous
sommes des alliés et nous avons
conscience de la responsabilité que nous
portons dans ce projet dans le réseau
Guy Hoquet on a une particularité par
rapport aux autres réseaux c'est que la
formation et je pense que c'est un point
stratégique pour bien conseiller et
informer le particulier la formation et
gratuite et illimitée et depuis le début
de l'année nous avons dispensé 2300
heures de formation à l'ensemble des
conseillers que ce soit de gestion
locative ou de transaction dans le
réseau nous travaillons aussi avec des
organismes comme les opérateurs de
compétences des entreprises de proximité
sur les sujets de formation et de
financement des formations à la
transition environnementale des
logements nous travaillons avec la Nil
avec Lana et nous avons mis en place des
partenariats nationaux et locaux pour
aider les particuliers aussi bien à
trouver des financements à adresser des
aides avec la difficulté qu'on vient de
voir et à sourcer des entreprises de
reconnus garantes de l'environnement
pour pouvoir réaliser des travaux
donc nous sommes prêts
mais effectivement pour répondre aux
questions que vous avez posées madame la
Présidente nous avons besoin d'aide pour
avoir les moyens d'inciter les Français
qu'ils soient en logement individuel ou
en copropriété à agir
et nous avons envie aujourd'hui vous
alerter sur trois points principaux
certains ont déjà été soulevés donc je
ne
m'attarderai pas dessus le premier point
c'est le diagnostic de performance
énergétique
tout d'abord sur sa fiabilité
effectivement parce qu'on sait que c'est
un vrai sujet un vrai enjeu il a été
récemment démontré potentiellement qu'il
pouvait impacter négativement les
petites surfaces notamment il est vrai
aussi qu'on a deux méthodologies au
final qui
survivent encore si je puis dire en tout
cas qui coexistent en fonction du cas du
propriétaire selon qu'on soit en
transaction notamment puisque l'ancienne
méthodologie court encore pour certains
donc comment avec deux méthodologie
différentes
on a des propriétaires qui sont soumis
au même contrainte notamment
d'interdiction d'A les loyers ou
d'interdiction bientôt de mettre à la
location ça c'est le premier point et
puis évidemment l'organisation de la
filière des diagnostiqueurs alors je ne
parlerai pas pour eux je sais que vous
avez déjà reçu ici la filière des
diagnostiqueurs mais c'est un des
véritables enjeux pour nous pour
accompagner les Français dans ce défi le
deuxième point sur lequel nous avons
besoin absolument
de d'avoir des renforts et des réponses
parce que nous constatons sur le terrain
qui ne sont pas encore adaptés aux
besoins des Français adaptés au pilotage
de la transition environnementale nous
avons besoin ce sont les solutions de
financement alors par solution de
financement bien entendu on a beaucoup
parlé des aides alors nous sommes
conscients que l'État ne peut pas tout
même si effectivement il faut saluer le
fait qu'il soit mobilisé mais au-delà
des aides et de l'avance qui est souvent
très difficile à faire pour les ménages
d'ailleurs qui sont éligibles aux aides
le sujet c'est vraiment les solutions de
financement privé donc j'entends
effectivement par là les établissements
bancaires et les établissements calcaire
aujourd'hui nous objette à juste titre
qu'il est difficile pour eux d'évaluer
le montant des travaux notamment dans le
cas d'une mutation d'un bien
c'est-à-dire d'une vente et qu'il est
difficile pour eux d'aller contrôler le
fait que le montant alloué ait été était
utilisé effectivement à la rénovation
énergétique et puis si on prend le cas
des copropriété vous posiez la question
tout à l'heure des freins il y a
énormément de freins ont été soulevés
par les intervenants ici mais ce qu'on
voit aussi aujourd'hui c'est que
seulement deux banques proposent les
co-préat taux zéro
Domofinance pour ne pas les citer et la
Caisse d'Epargne Île-de-France
uniquement donc si on veut effectivement
accélérer la transition environnementale
des copropriétés il y a énormément de
solutions encore à actionner comme elles
ont été citées mais celle-ci me semble
nécessaire et enfin le troisième point
et ce sera mon dernier
ce sont les entreprises reconnues
garantes de l'environnement puisque
le président de la CAPEB rappelait
récemment que sur les 560 000 artisanale
du bâtiment seulement 63000 sont
labellisées RGE que c'est un nombre qui
a tendance à reculer d'année en année
puisqu'en 2001 elles étaient 65000 et
nous parlons à très court terme de
rénover 5,2 millions de passoires
énergétique et je considère donc
uniquement les biens F et G 63000
entreprises pour 5,2 millions bien dans
un calendrier qui est effectivement très
ambitieux ça pose question alors j'ai vu
que Bruno Le Maire visait 250 000
entreprises RGO mais il nous a pas
encore expliqué quels étaient les moyens
qui comptaient mettre en oeuvre donc
voilà ces trois sujets qui comme le
comme j'emploie la même expression ou la
même image que Monsieur Frémont
c'est-à-dire que ce soit aujourd'hui des
freins mais ça ils peuvent devenir aussi
des leviers importants mais pour nous
ces sujets doivent être résolus pour
qu'on puisse justement jouer notre rôle
de facilitateur en tant qu'agent
immobilier en termes que gestionnaire
locatif gestionnaire de copropriété au
syndic pour pouvoir accompagner les
Français et pour pouvoir justement tenir
ce calendrier extrêmement ambitieux
merci beaucoup madame donc on continue
avec Madame Laurence Mattel qui est donc
au niveau des la gestion immobilière
Foncia ADB oui merci madame la
Présidente bonjour à toutes et à tous
donc effectivement Foncia est un
administrateur de bien premier loueur en
France avec 400000 biens sous gestion et
premier syndic de France avec 70 000
immeubles gérés et Foncia s'est engagé
depuis 2021 de manière extrêmement
volontariste dans la rénovation
énergétique de des biens sous gestion
alors ça veut dire quoi s'engager de
manière extrêmement volontariste ça veut
dire que 100% de nos gestionnaires sont
formés ça veut dire que nous avons des
référents travaux rénovation
énergétiques dans l'ensemble de la
France ça veut dire que nous avons en
2022 signer un Green Deal avec le Plan
Bâtiment Durable dans lequel nous sommes
engagés à rénover 300
immeubles complets d'ici 2025 et adapt
donc depuis 2022 nous avons déjà plus de
copropriétés en rénovation c'est plus de
15000 logements en rénovation globale
qui sont aujourd'hui engagés chez Foncia
et puis nous accompagnons nos bailleurs
individuels pour leur permettre au
travers de d'études très approfondies de
s'engager dans des travaux pour
améliorer leur étiquette énergétique
donc tout ça pour vous dire qu'on
commence à avoir un bon observatoire de
ce qui se passe sur le terrain et aussi
une forte conviction qui est que la
rénovation du résidentiel le cœur de
cette rénovation c'est la copropriété et
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas le logement
enfin le bailleur
cette conviction s'articule derrière
autour de plusieurs propositions et je
voudrais revenir sur trois propositions
de non pas encore été évoqué une a déjà
été évoquée la première qui est assez
simple et qui concerne les le calendrier
25 28 pour les bailleurs sans remettre
en cause ce calendrier 25-28 il nous
semblerait très pertinent que cette
interdiction de louer si le bien n'est
pas la bonne étiquette énergétique soit
à la remise en location et non pas au
cours du bail je m'explique faire des
travaux d'isolation par l'intérieur
quand le bien est occupé n'est pas
possible je vais vous illustrer ça de
manière très simple vous avez une
cuisine qui est accroché sur un mur qui
donne sur votre cours que vous devez
isoler pour pouvoir passer une étiquette
une meilleure étiquette il faut déposer
la cuisine isoler reposer la cuisine et
ça ça se fait en milieu inoccupé ça ne
se fait pas en milieu
occupé et d'ailleurs la loi climat est
résilient sur 2023 et les biens les plus
énergivores dit bien que ça la remise en
location que le bien est interdit à la
location et non pas au cours du bail
donc ça c'est la première proposition
extrêmement simple extrêmement
pragmatique seconde proposition elle
concerne l'articulation et et l'umpi la
évoqué l'articulation entre le bailleur
enfin les les obligations qui pèsent sur
le bailleur et les obligations qui
pèsent sur la copropriété dans la loi
climat résilience aujourd'hui cette
articulation est relativement faible et
là aussi nous avons une proposition
extrêmement pragmatique à vous suggérer
qui est celle-ci à partir du moment où
un bailleur privé à un logement qui est
au sein d'une copropriété et que cette
copropriété s'est engagée dans un plan
pluriannuel de travaux avec rénovation
énergétique ou dans un ravalement de
façade avec isolation par l'extérieur à
ce moment là et qui peut prendre du
temps comme Monsieur safare l'expliqué
ça peut prendre du temps dans ce cadre
là le le les obligations de la loi
climat et résilience sont suspendus le
temps que les travaux de la copropriété
puissent être réalisés et ça ça
évidemment un double intérêt c'est un
intérêt évidemment financier écologique
financier pour le bailleur qui n'aura
pas supporté deux fois les travaux une
fois par l'intérieur une fois par
l'extérieur écologique parce qu'on
n'aura pas à mettre deux fois des
relation une fois par l'intérieur et une
fois par l'extérieur avec une empreinte
CO2 doublée sur l'isolation et puis
quelque part cette obligation qui porte
sur le bailleur et qui est peu articulée
avec la copro et presque
contre-productif pour la rénovation en
copropriété puisque un bailleur qui
s'est engagé en amont dans l'isolation
enfin dans la rénovation individuelle
privative de son logement sera un
fervent opposant au moment de la du vote
en copropriété pour la rénovation
globale parce qu'il ne voudra pas payer
deux fois donc pour nous il est
important de mieux articuler ce sujet et
puis enfin troisième proposition qui a
déjà été largement évoquée qui est
autour du financement de la rénovation
globale en copropriété effectivement bon
Etienne notamment de kerese notamment
évoqué les subventions qui sont
importantes et qu'il faut souligner il
faut souligner l'effort qui est fait en
la matière et globalement sur une
réservation qui coûte 100 aujourd'hui on
peut avoir 70 de restes à charge et 30
de subventions en moyenne ce que nous
proposons et parce que les coprais taux
zéro et globalement
inefficace ce que nous proposons c'est
la mise en place d'un éco prête au zéro
copro qui avec le syndicat qui emprunte
et non et non chacun des des
copropriétaires avec un emprunt qui est
remboursé et qui est attaché au lot et
qui donc suit le Lot au gré des
mutations
avec un prêt zéro ce qui globalement
coûte finalement assez peu cher parce
que quand on regarde un peu il doit y
avoir à peu près 1 million six alors
selon la police les manifestants ça peut
être un peu différent mais globalement
un million six de logements en
copropriété à rénover ce que l'on a pu
voir sur les 210 rénovations que le que
l'on est en train de faire c'est qu'en
moyenne c'est 20000 euros par logement
après subvention on est aux alentours de
15000 euros par logement donc ça veut
dire que cette rénovation globalement va
coûter aux copropriétaires
24 25 milliards d'euros un éco prête au
0 à 4% le coût pour l'État globalement
c'est 8 milliards sur 15 ans étalé sur
15 ans donc c'est pas forcément très
significatif et ça peut être un
véritable levier pour accélérer la
rénovation énergétique en copropriété
qui est le cœur du sujet
merci beaucoup donc on passe au groupe
Nexity avec mesdames Olivier et Rognard
bonjour Merci
alors au même titre que Foncia chez
Nexity on est là pour traduire un peu ce
qui se passe sur le terrain on est des
vrais capteurs plus d'un million de
clients 700000 copropriétaires 200.000
bailleurs des locataires des acquéreurs
des vendeurs donc une vue assez large de
ce qui se passe avec un véritable
engagement on a signé ensemble le Green
Deal 2 sur lequel on a mis des objectifs
afin 2025 assez fort pour rénover un
certain nombre de biens copropriété et
bien sûr participer à des audits
énergétiques pour nos propriétaires
bailleurs moi ce qui m'intéresse alors
s'il fallait faire un petit clin d'oeil
au CNR d'hier et aux propositions qui
ont été faites j'avoue que quand on nous
dit augmenter significativement le
nombre de mon incapadiateur rénove de
2000 à 5000 j'allais dire nous sommes
des accompagnateurs rénovs donc si on en
a des problèmes d'idées et de budget je
pense qu'on peut se reposer sur les
syndics de copropriété et nous utilisons
au regard du nombre et puis du maillage
territorial que nous avons parce que
notre job c'est d'accompagner
globalement nos clients copropriétaires
et bailleurs sur un accompagnement qui
est technique certes mais qui est aussi
sociale et financier
ce qui est important de savoir c'est
qu'en fait la rénovation énergétique
aujourd'hui elle marche on a plus de
7000 logements régionaux de mauvais en
copropriété on vient de lancer passer le
cap des milles audites énergétiques à la
demande des propriétaires bailleurs
simplement si maintenant on est dans un
mode d'accélération il y a des points
d'amélioration qu'il faut faire je me
permets juste également de souligner
qu'il faut jamais dissocier le monde de
la copropriété du monde du parc locatif
privé parce que je rappelle que sur les
7 millions d'euros 7 millions 3 de
logements du parc privé locatif il y en
a un million 7 qui sont étiquettes
énergétiques FPG et que si on s'est un
million 7 il y en a quand même un
million deux soit 70% qui sont en
copropriété donc ce qui est toujours
difficile pour nous c'est quand il y a
des lois qui sont différentes alors
qu'en fait on parle des mêmes des mêmes
des mêmes sujets les motivations sont là
pour faire la rénovation énergétique les
freins aussi alors on a réfléchi à
quelques solutions alors je vais pas
reprendre il y a plein de choses sur
lesquelles je suis entièrement d'accord
je vais essayer d'aller sur des
solutions dont on va parler ça apporte
essayer d'apporter quelque chose je suis
ok pour un prêt
copro et collectif la seule chose c'est
que je souhaiterais que ce prêt englobe
les travaux le reste à charge et
également les avances de subventions
parce qu'on oublie toujours que les
subventions sont versées à la livraison
des travaux et donc quand on fait
on fait un montage financier auprès de
nos copropriétaires ils ne comprennent
pas que dans le reste à charge on vient
ajouter les subventions et donc il y a
un effet de temps qui est assez complexe
à faire valider je vais venir sur un
point dont personne n'a parlé mais qui
me semblait essentielle qui est le droit
de la copropriété
on a en fait en assemblée générale
aujourd'hui il faut la majorité totale
avec une possibilité de dérogation pour
une majorité simple notre vision c'est
que on peut aller plus vite en passant
directement la majorité simple c'est à
dire majorité des présents et
représentés pourquoi aujourd'hui
participer à l'assemblée générale un
c'est le devoir du citoyen c'est la vie
de son immeuble deux je crois qu'on a
tout mis en place pour qu'il puisse
participer présent à présent votre parc
correspondance à distance en visio il
n'y a pas une raison qui fait qu'on ne
puisse pas participer à son assemblée
générale le deuxième point sur lesquels
je vais revenir c'est le recours
on a des recours sur nos projets le
problème c'est que le recours il est
autorisé aussi pour les copropriétaires
qui ne participent pas au vote et donc à
la vie de l'immeuble et donc dès que
vous avez un recours sur un immeuble
qu'est-ce qui se passe le pré collectif
en tout cas le prêt bancaire il est
suspendu il est bloqué jusqu'à
l'extinction du recours
et toutes les aides et subventions que
vous avez acquises Anna après ma prime
rénov ce que vous voulez et ben en fait
vu qu'elles ont une date butoir et que
ces recours durent un certain temps tout
le financement tombe par terre donc ça
c'est un vrai sujet je dis pas qu'il
faut interdire le recours pour ceux qui
étaient là bien évidemment mais en tout
cas si on ne participe pas au vote je
vois pas pourquoi on bloque et si on
veut accélérer à mon sens ça peut être
une idée
je reviens également sur le le bailleur
et la loi climat résilience complètement
d'accord à ce quasi Laurence relatif
donc à cette problématique il faut
adapter le calendrier et simplement
déclencher l'interdiction de louer à la
remise en location ça c'est sûr vous
savez que le marché locatif est bloqué
on parle de bombe social je me permets
de reprendre ce terme parce que je pense
que c'est une réalité qu'on verra un peu
l'état de la France en septembre
il y a beaucoup de ventes alors on a
fait on a interrogé 9000 propriétaires
chez nous qui sont étiquettes g donc
très très concernés par un calendrier
très court un tiers accepte de faire des
audits énergétiques et ont les moyens
d'aller jusqu'au bout un tiers disent
non je ne bougerai pas le calendrier va
bouger et en plus j'ai un locataire en
place et un tiers dit je ne sais pas
faire je n'ai pas de pouvoir d'achat je
ne peux pas faire les travaux donc je
vais vendre aujourd'hui on n'a pas un
raz-de-marée des ventes et j'ai pas vrai
c'est trop tôt en tout cas on en a
quelques-unes ça se prépare je pense
qu'il y a un temps long je pense que nos
propriétaires attendent en revanche on
commence à avoir des décodes sur les
biens c'était une de vos questions entre
6 et 10% en fonction des territoires
il y a une chose qui me choque pour les
bailleurs c'est que notamment dans des
villes qui proposent l'encadrement des
loyers
l'étiquette énergétique n'est pas du
tout prise en compte dans les
dérogations possibles que nous pouvons
faire donc c'est double peine c'est à
dire qu'il faut faire des travaux et
qu'en plus on a des loyers bloqués et
qu'on n'a pas le droit d'utiliser
l'étiquette énergétique ce qui ne me
semble pas très juste donc ça c'est un
point que je voulais mentionner et puis
le dernier point pour revenir sur le
monde de la copropriété c'est la
difficulté des aides
voilà je crois que Gilles Frémont a
illustrer tout ce qui ce qui venait donc
vous nous posez la question de savoir si
on pouvait encore plus réglementer vous
allez dire je sais même pas comment font
nos collaborateurs pour s'y retrouver
donc non s'il vous plaît arrêtons de
tout réglementer mais trouvons des
solutions assez simples et surtout pour
terminer si on pouvait remettre les
syndics de copropriété dans la boucle et
si vous pouviez tous vous appuyez sur
nous parce que c'est notre métier notre
savoir-faire et notre passion on est
engagé de faire l'innovation énergétique
je pense que ça ferait avancer merci
beaucoup merci à vous madame Rognard
pour l'instant ça suffit d'accord donc
la Fédération des promoteurs immobiliers
je vous laisse la parole aux uns aux
autres madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur merci pour cette audition
merci aussi de nous avoir sollicité
puisque la FP est souvent assimilée ou
neuf en réalité les opérateurs que nous
sommes intervenons de plus en plus sur
le sujet de la rénovation pour un petit
rappel donc la FPI c'est 700 adhérents
représentent à peu près 80% du marché de
la production de logements qui soit neuf
ou réhabilité l'art particularité c'est
qu'on a une fédération plurielle on a
des acteurs de petite taille moi même je
suis opérateur petite opérateur mais
également des grands nationaux et donc
on représente une frange assez large et
on touche une clientèle également très
large qui va du logement primo-accédant
au logement haut de gamme en passant par
le logement social et c'est un rappel
important puisque à l'issue du CNR il
faut pas oublier que le privé représente
54% de la production de logements
sociaux donc quand le bâtiment neuf ne
va pas bien c'est également le logement
abordable c'est également le locatif
abordable et le locatif social qui sont
pénalisés donc une fois qu'on a dit ça
conscient de ces problématiques de plus
en plus importantes sur la
réhabilitation on a souhaité monter une
commission commission réhabilitation
extension qui est un sujet qu'on n'a pas
trop abordé et rénovation parce
qu'effectivement notre métier lié donc
aux différentes contraintes qu'on peut
avoir liées aux ânes liées aussi à une
politique locale qui qui est assez
fébrile sur le fait de densifier en cœur
de ville la rénovation est une solution
clairement identifiée
donc on s'y met dans ce dispositif là
depuis maintenant plusieurs années et la
conclusion c'est qu'on a quand même
plusieurs contraintes les contraintes
qu'on a c'est d'abord nous on a un
opérateur qui a réalisé des rénovations
complètes donc on est effectivement
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu aborder
jusqu'à maintenant on raisonne pas
format copropriété on raisonne format
immeuble entier et quand on prend un
immeuble on le restaure et pour le coup
le restore extérieur intérieur on le
restaure à l'échelle de l'immeuble et à
l'échelle du logement donc on a une
approche globale les contraintes qu'on a
par rapport à cette cette organisation
de production c'est que notre matière
première est cher les immeubles qu'on
achète ils sont toujours en coeur de
ville et ils ont toujours une valeur
vénale qui est
réel qui est importante nous avons des
travaux qui sont des travaux
d'adaptation qui sont des travaux lourds
et qui coûtent très cher quand je dis
très cher il coûte plus cher que de
faire un immeuble neuf donc ça il faut
l'avoir aussi en tête et on est
également dans un travail d'adaptation
puisque chaque immeuble a ses
pathologies et d'ailleurs on en parlait
tout à l'heure monsieur la garde le
disait les immeubles ont leur propre
pathologie et à chaque immeuble une
solution technique adaptée et un produit
adapté
donc la conclusion c'est que pour
réaliser des opérations et pour
massifier ce sujet là il faut pouvoir
adresser une clientèle et solvabilité il
solvabiliser une clientèle donc un des
premiers éléments on va dire très
absents du discours hier qu'on a fait
d'abord aussi vert c'est comment est-ce
qu'on redonne de la solvabilité à nos
acquéreurs qui soient accédant ou
investisseurs comment est-ce qu'on
travaille sur les règles de solvabilité
donc les règles CSF tout ça c'est des
éléments qui s'ils ne sont pas résolus
notamment trompe pas de faire la chaîne
d'après c'est-à-dire la réalisation les
travaux et les livraisons alors face à
tous ces problèmes là qu'est-ce que nous
on peut porter comme discours le premier
c'est on en a parlé un petit peu tout à
l'heure il faut qu'on ait une stabilité
sur les normes donc nous on appelait ça
une pause normative il ne faut pas
changer tout le temps de règle fiscales
il ne faut pas changer les éléments qui
permettent de produire du logement
réhabilité que sont le Malraux le
donormandie tous ces éléments là sont à
pérenniser et je continue aussi à penser
que le prêt taux zéro est quelque chose
qu'il faut pérenniser et qu'il ne faut
pas recentrer sur une frange très
réduite de la production
le deuxième élément c'est que pour nous
il faut si on veut être efficace lécher
les aides pour la fiscalité à des
immeubles de rénover dans leur
intégralité aujourd'hui le 2 Normandie
dans un exemple on peut faire du
non-normandie à titre personnel en
achetant un logement dans une
copropriété mais en réalité il est
intéressant de voir que pour qu'une
rénovation soit réussie il faut que ce
soit tout l'immeuble qui soit rénové et
pas simplement un appartement dans une
copropriété donc on préconise un
fléchage des aides à des immeubles
rénovés par des professionnels que nous
sommes
un autre élément du coup qui est
important qu'on évoquait aussi c'est la
fluidité sur les immeubles je disais que
les immeubles sont chers aujourd'hui la
fiscalité est au profit de la détention
plus on détient son bien et quand on le
revendra moins la plus-value sera
importante ça faisait partie des
propositions qui n'ont pas été retenues
au CNR inverser la fiscalité pour
permettre du coup une fluidification des
immeubles qui parfois sont dans des
cœurs de ville détenus par des familles
de très longue date et qui ne bougent
pas et qui sont parfois délabrés tout
simplement parce que la détention ne
coûte rien
le dernier point qui nous paraît
important et c'est lié à l'extension et
c'est un point qu'on n'a pas trop abordé
je mets de côté les contraintes les
contraintes liées à les accords de
copropriété à voir pour faire une
rénovation mais comment on sait le coût
que se représente une rénovation
complète d'un immeuble on préconise
l'idée de dire qu'on pourrait sur chaque
immeuble faire une réhausse qui serait
inscrite dans l'accord avec la
collectivité d'en faire un immeuble de
plus qui permettrait de valoriser un
étage de plus pardon qui permettrait de
valoriser
les droits à construire qui ne sont pas
utilisés et qui permettrait de
réinjecter de l'argent dans la
rénovation complète des immeubles donc
voilà quelques propositions qui du coup
élargissent aussi un peu le débat sur la
notion de rénovation et de
restructuration d'immeubles mais qui
sont effectivement forcément travaillés
avec l'ensemble des parties puisqu'on ne
sait pas faire d'immeubles sans avoir
une relation avec des copropriétaires et
donc on est dans l'obligation d'aller
sur ces démarches là merci
est-ce que vous voulez rajouter quelque
chose Monsieur si vous me le permettez
la présidente merci beaucoup je dirais
que d'abord en complément de ce qui
vient de Pierre quasiment neuf
opérations sur 10 en 9 sont faites sur
des terrains des gens artificialisés
donc je crois qu'il est aussi important
de dire que quand on parle de rénovation
l'acte 9 fait partie de l'activité de
rénovation de la ville
deuxième élément on oppose souvent
rénovation et reconstruction ou
extension reconstruction
l'écart emploi carbone d'une
réhabilitation
rénovation et du neuf
performant est extrêmement faible et ce
chiffre autour de 100 kg de CO2 par
mètre carré par an en analyse de cycle
de vie sur un volume global de 800 vous
voyez qu'on est sur des écarts assez
faibles et j'insiste là dessus parce que
un des non-dits dans la rénovation c'est
la problématique de la durée de vie
individuel de l'ouvrage nos collègues de
l'Union sociale pour l'habitat ont mis
en place un process sur le principe du
deuxième vie seconde vie des bâtiments
absolument et vous comprenez bien que là
le sujet qui nous parle à nous
promoteurs qui sommes en charge de
refaire la ville pour nous concitoyens
mais aussi d'avoir une vision holistique
sur la durée de vie résiduelle de
l'ouvrage à quel est l'intérêt d'aller
rénover un ouvrage si la durée de vie
résiduelle est de 20 ans en termes de
carbone en termes d'énergie en termes
d'investissement donc on a bien là un
enjeu extrêmement important ou comme le
disait pierre vital l'approche du
promoteur sur l'immeuble complet peut
avoir un effet extrêmement positif sur
la durée de vie complémentaire d'une
rénovation complète ou bien sur une
approche de démolition de bâtiments
obsolètes pour refaire du neuf
ultra performant je rappelle madame la
Présidente que le 9 en France c'est la
réglementation la plus performante au
monde
les deux très loin que ce soit sur
l'énergie ou le carbone donc je pense
que là on a un enjeu extrêmement
important de ne plus opposer mais de
bien travailler sur une vision macro et
micro projet par projet de quel est ce
qui est le plus intéressant de faire
rénové rénover xtence rénovation
extension comme le disait pierre ou bien
démolir et reconstruire et ne plus
opposer les éléments donc ça c'est pour
moi extrêmement important d'autant plus
que
nous avons maintenant aussi un label dit
BBC et synergie
qui nous permettrait aussi de labelliser
nos opérations de rénovation globale et
fléchi les aides vers des opérations de
rénovation globale qui disposeraient de
ce label donc si on a aussi les moyens
et les outils pour aborder cette
rénovation globale et répondre à des
critères qui sont beaucoup plus
performants que la rénovation dite
réglementation thermique par composant
si vous me permettez je ferai aussi un
commentaire sur les problématiques
évoquées sur les modes de calcul du
diagnostic de performance énergétique de
la réglementation environnementale etc
je trouve quand même surprenant qu'après
dans le cas de mes fonctions j'ai eu à
présider la Fédération européenne des
ingénieurs climaticiens avec 27
associations nationales nous avons pu
travailler pendant 10 ans sur un corpus
normatif européen et je trouve toujours
étonnant que au niveau français alors
que l'enjeu est de refaire l'urbain et
les immeubles de toute la France on soit
encore en train de travailler avec des
moteurs de calcul qui sont ceux il y a
20 ans qui sont ceux qui ont été
développés avec des algorithmes dit il a
20 ans je trouve complètement fou que
l'État l'administration ne se donne pas
les moyens en termes de temps et de
moyens financiers de nous mettre à
disposition un moteur de calcul global
qui permettrait de faire le calcul
théorique est conventionnel le calcul en
approche de simulation réelle de la
consommation le calcul carbone dont on
émission annuelle qu'on émission en
analyse de ce club de vie et pourquoi je
vous dis ça madame la Présidente parce
que il y a un projet qui a été initié
par nos collègues du CSTB et d'autres
experts qui s'appelle le projet cible
alors on nous annonce que dans cinq ans
le cahier des charges sera écrit
excusez-moi madame la séatrice mais je
pense que la France peut avoir les
moyens d'une ambition forte sur ce sujet
là à double titre c'est premièrement on
a besoin d'un outil puissant qui crée la
confiance avec nos concitoyens et pas la
défiance comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
et deuxièmement il y a un corpus
européen qui nous permet aussi peut-être
de travailler en coopération avec nos
collègues d'autres pays européens pour
le mettre à disposition de pays qui
n'ont peut-être pas les moyens de le
développer il s'agit pas je vous parle
pas là de milliards d'euros je vous
parle là d'investissement millions
d'euros et notre fédération il y a
quelques années lorsque la herova était
sur la table avait proposé un
partenariat public privé
pour travailler ensemble avec tous les
acteurs à la création de cet outil qui
nous concerne tous ce n'est pas un outil
discrétionnaire qui doit être uniquement
piloté par quelques experts au niveau de
l'administration je suis convaincu que
si nous travaillons tous ensemble avec
gouvernance d'un outil de ce type
rapidement en se donnant les moyens de
créer un outil qui génère la confiance
nous y gagnerions tous et surtout je
crois que la même chose pourrait se
faire sur les observatoires puisque on
parle beaucoup de travaux mais enfin la
consommation énergétique des logements
la consommation énergétique finale
depuis 40 ans les 450 à 500 TT
c'est pas une courbe c'est une droite
donc on nous demande d'intervenir sur
une réduction de la consommation
d'intervenir sur une réduction des gaz à
effet de serre on n'a pas un outil qui
nous permet de le faire de manière
fiable en général la confiance et on
nous demande d'accélérer parce que nous
n'avons pas évoqué ici la feuille de
route sur la décarbonation qui est
apparemment complètement décorrélé des
travaux sur la rénovation énergétique
vous voyez on est on a besoin de
recentrer nos outils de retravailler sur
l'approche et les moyens qu'on se donne
et de fixer des objectifs non pas de
moyens mais d'objet de résultat sur la
performance des travaux qui sont mis en
oeuvre et ceci aussi est en cours avec
les travaux dans le cas du programme
profil et du programme sereine que vous
connaissez et qui pourraient être
accéléré si on s'en donne les moyens je
vous remercie madame la Présidente merci
Madame pericaud non c'est bon alors nous
ont rejoint je vous avais déjà présenté
monsieur le Président de la FNI monsieur
Loïc Cantat et sa chef de cabinet
benaddict Rouault donc je vais vous
demander de vous prêter un formalisme
auxquels sont prêtés l'ensemble des
autres participants à cette table ronde
c'est-à-dire de lever la main droite de
dire la vérité toute la vérité et je le
jure voilà et donc comme ça vous
terminez ce tour de table déjà très
complet et très vaste je vous laisse la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
bien merci de nous entendre dans le
cadre de ce dispositif et de la
rénovation énergétique qui impacte tous
les Français et particulièrement le parc
immobilier alors l'effetnam c'est fini
il y a beaucoup de syndics de
copropriété qui seront chargés qui sont
chargés de ces rénovations et aussi
nombre d'administrateurs de biens
d'agents immobiliers je le ferai un pas
un paragraphe tout à l'heure sur les
agents immobiliers comment aussi peuvent
être acteurs de la rénovation
énergétique mais notre profession est
engagée depuis longtemps dans le
processus de rénovation énergétique
depuis je dirais la loi Grenelle de
l'environnement nous sommes saisis de ce
sujet au de cycle de formation auprès de
nos syndics de copropriété pendant le
covid nous avons pas moins assuré plus
de la formation de 1500 syndics pour
1500 syndic pour s'y préparer au travers
du programme coproverte et rénovo facile
donc c'est tout à dispositif qui est mis
en œuvre pour pouvoir accompagner la
politique publique et les obligations
qui sont notamment celles de la France
et aussi celle de la Commission
européenne d'avoir un parc des carboné à
l'horizon 2050 et plus précisément à
l'horizon 2030 donc le dire le temps
presse et simplement nous sommes là pour
évaluer les outils et notamment les
dispositions et l'environnement
réglementaire et juridique auquel nous
sommes confrontés
nombre de mes collègues mes confrères
ont déjà développé j'entendais ça
pendant la course pour venir vous
rejoindre j'ai écouté quand même partie
des débats que je vais rejoindre je
développerai pas je pense que Olivier
Safar a introduit notamment la
temporalité de la copropriété au travers
de ta maman la mise en œuvre à travers
les différentes phases de retenue d'une
décision de résolution devant être
adapté par l'assemblée générale et en
plus compléter du financement de
l'obtention des primes de la sélection
des entreprises le vote des travaux les
éventuels recours la temporalité de la
copropriété n'est pas celle qui figure
et qui pourrait être exigée par les
pouvoirs publics nous avons un temps qui
est celui de la vie de la copropriété et
je dirais il faut bien l'intégrer au
regard de ces enjeux et c'est vrai que
quand on regarde l'autre calendrier de
la rénovation énergétique où on a
finalement interdit la location ou
frapper d'indécence des logements qui ne
seraient pas placé j'ai ceux qui
seraient au 1er janvier 2025 et Ève 2028
suspendent la naissance de ses logements
heart et notamment n'est pas productif
pour le marché locatif au contraire
provoque une attrition de celui-ci et
qui est mauvaise la mauvaise signal
alors c'est vrai que la fenium depuis
longtemps je l'ai entendu réclamer de
suspendre c'est un licence énergétique à
l'adoption d'un planning de travaux dès
lors qu'un syndicat de copropriétaire
s'engage ce serait une preuve
effectivement d'aller et de d'exécuter
ses travaux et cette suspension de la
décence pour être de bon ton nous avons
tout tenté tout proposer auprès du mise
au logement près différents services et
malheureusement nous ne sommes pas
entendu
quelque chose aussi qui nous inquiète
c'est
les deux DPE qui s'opposent entre un DPE
collectif et un DPE individuel qui
peuvent être différents l'un de l'autre
un moment il va falloir faire un choix
sur un DPE le DPE collectif nous semble
le seul DPE qui puisse notamment éviter
notamment une opposition entre
copropriétaires on pourrait très bien
avoir un DPE individuel différent du DPE
collectif et avoir une procédure
contentieuse notamment si le DPE
collectif était plus favorable et d'un
classement supérieur des peurs
individuels
mais j'ai entendu également parler du
financement le financement c'est quelque
chose qui nous intéresse et depuis un
moment la FNA s'est saisi d'une démarche
auprès du gouvernement la Banque de
France lequel a répondu d'ailleurs
favorablement à cette demande en
précisant qu'il s'agissait qu'une
adaptation réglementaire le financement
de la copropriété quel que soit je
dirais la forme de prêt
est néanmoins après collectif mais qui
est analysé au regard de la
réglementation bancaire comme la
succession d'un endettement en autant de
copropriétaires qui auront recours qui
composent le syndicat des
copropriétaires
et à ce titre le cumul de l'ensemble des
prêts souscrits par la totalité la
collectivité du syndicat des
copropriétaires excède la somme de 75000
euros qui est le seuil de le tuto de
l'usure entre prêt à la consommation et
prêt immobilier
et cette addition de prêt qui excède
75000 francs fait assimiler l'emprunt un
prêt immobilier qui lui-même est
subdivisé entre des prêts individuelles
et qui doit être géré comme tel et
notamment qui n'est pas je dirais
suffisamment à cet été pour les banques
le gouvernement de la Banque de France a
répondu en ces termes qu'il s'agissait
d'une adaptation réglementaire
permettant justement de faire en sorte
de débloquer ce taux d'usure que le taux
d'usure même en additionnant l'ensemble
de ces prêts individuels sollicités dans
le cas d'une structure collective
pourrait être des prêts soumis au taux
d'usure liés auprès de la consommation
c'est une disposition qui est de nature
aussi à débloquer peut-être le
financement qui n'est toujours pas réglé
pour lequel nous n'avons pas de réponse
je dirais les différentes instances et
malgré nos réclamation parce
qu'aujourd'hui il est vrai que le reste
à charge des copropriétaires doit être
rassuré et doit être financée
les règles de majorité nous en avons
entendu parler et le ministre du
logement s'est fait l'écho de vouloir
abaisser de plus loin de novembre la
règle de majorité en copropriété
j'aurais revenir sur l'histoire
l'histoire c'est celle de la loi Elan
lorsque nous avons élaboré les
ordonnances sur la copropriété et le
travail nombreux qui a été fait et
fastidieux sur lequel nous sommes mis
d'accord déjà à cette époque on nous
avait proposé
et certains avaient proposé de ramener
la règle de majorité visant à décider
des travaux de rénovation énergétique de
l'article 25 à l'article 24 j'ai été
moi-même à fervent défenseur du maintien
de l'article 25 et notamment de façon à
assurer un bouclier protecteur auprès de
famille auprès de gens qui sont dans une
précarité et ne pas imposer une majorité
notamment à l'article 24 ou un seul
copropriétaire présent même sur 50
suffirait à décider de travaux de
rénovation la loi Elan a institué une
passerelle et cette passerelle notamment
permet si la résolution obtenue au moins
le tir des voix de décider la majorité
de l'article 24 nous avons déjà cette
parcelle qui s'être passerelle qui nous
permet justement en assurance ce
bouclier protecteur de décider à
l'article à majorité de l'article 24 dès
lors qu'on a eu au moins le tiers des
voies par le passé et au moment de la
loi alur nous avions un dispositif quand
un syndic de copropriété n'arrivait pas
à faire passer une décision d'article
lactique 25 il pouvait convoquer une
seconde
assemblée générale ce dispositif a été
supprimé je me suis entretenu avec
beaucoup de députés et j'ai accordé la
primeur de cette proposition notamment
retour récemment au cntgi pour dire que
finalement nous pourrions revenir
exceptionnel dans le cas de ces travaux
de rénovation énergétique finalement
c'est un bon compromis en toutes les
règles de majorité de pouvoir si jamais
à la majorité de l'article 25 terriens
vers la partie de l'article 25-1 qui
permet de décider à l'article majorité
de l'article 24 c'est la première
résolution et au moins le tiers mais si
elle n'est pas obtenue permettre aux
syndic à ce moment-là au conseil
syndical de reconvoquer une nouvelle
Assemblée Générale laquelle décidera à
la majorité exclusive de l'article 24
c'est à dire c'est un bon compromis
entre les deux entre le soit d'un
législateur de voir immédiatement
appliquer une majorité à l'article 24 là
entre deux temps on permet de protéger
des consommateurs et je pense que
beaucoup d'associations de consommateurs
y compris la Fondation Abbé Pierre nous
suivrons sur cette sur cette défense et
je les y sont très attachés permettent
effectivement
le respect et ce bouclier protecteur et
si la copropriété effectivement le
décide si un copropriétaire le demande
on peut refaire une nouvelle sommeil
vous savez en copropriété il y a
toujours la première assemblée générale
il faut toujours laisser un OS pour que
le chien s'amuse et je crois que la
deuxième Assemblée Générale sera propice
à une décision définitive et nous avons
une grande confiance et puis peut aussi
parce que la copropriété c'est un grand
travail de pédagogie et notamment de de
de communication
dans vos questionnaires j'ai vu sur les
questions posées une question qui m'a
interpellé qui est intéressante qu'elle
selon selon vous l'impact d'une
obligation de rénovation énergétique à
la mutation sur le marché immobilier
alors c'est une vraie question et là je
voudrais dire que finalement la
rénovation énergétique ce n'est pas que
les syndicats de copropriétaires et les
syndics je représente les trois
professions les administrateurs de bien
les agents immobiliers les syndics de
copropriété les syndics de copropriété
nous sommes tous confrontés à la
décision de travaux à mettre en oeuvre
administrateur de bien nous sommes
confrontés au quotidien par des
copropriétaires qui aujourd'hui leur
appartement est en frappé de la décence
sont amenés à se poser la décision de
vendre ne pas vendre nous sommes
conseillés régulièrement conseillère
régulièrement sur la décision à prendre
si nous devons entreprendre des travaux
comment faire donc les administrateurs
de biens qui ne sont pas sadiques de
copropriété pour cette fonction sont
confrontés directement un arbitrage
qu'ils doivent opérer
un agent immobilier aujourd'hui est
confronté dans le cadre de l'exercice de
son son activité entreprendre une
évaluation et aussi je dirais en étant
protégé d'avoir un DPE individuel pour
attester le classement énergétique du
bien depuis le premier avril 2023 les
ventes d'immeubles en monopropriété
c'est à dire les maisons individuelles
ou les immeubles en bloc ce qui est plus
rare les maisons individuelles sont
assorties d'un audit énergétique cette
Audi fixe notamment et cadre le montant
des travaux entreprendre pour atteindre
une classe énergétique d'un montant
supérieur en quelque sorte l'agent
immobilier demain va être finalement un
faciliateur du parcours notamment des
français et notamment vis-à-vis afin
d'intégrer cette valeur énergétique et
notamment de la commenter
la directive la Commission européenne
vise à notamment à ce que aujourd'hui et
demain on est une transparence totale
sur le classement la FNA va proposer
dans quelques jours une proposition
originale et j'en fais état devant vous
c'est vrai que je vous donne un exemple
un agent immobilier qui fait de la
transaction hier il évaluait une maison
à 300000 euros dans son des peurs lui au
saut d'audit on lui dit les travaux au
Val 50 000 la question devons-nous
majorer ces travaux de sur le prix sur
les 300 000 nous devons-nous les
diminuer c'est 100 000 euros sur 300.000
c'est le tiers l'arbitrage il va pas
s'opérer là et on peut pas maintenir un
tel système quand on fait de
l'évaluation de l'expertise la valeur
qui va s'imposer demain c'est la valeur
verte et on y coupera pas donc c'est pas
la valeur sans travaux c'est la valeur
avec travaux et celle-ci celle-ci qui va
servir d'étalonnage et de repérage alors
comment y parvenir
soit on ne fait rien
et si on ne fait rien à un moment le
législateur nous l'imposera
d'autorité une retenue sur un prix
de façon arbitraire non contrôlée et ça
nous ne voulons pas au contraire les
professionnels de l'immobilier sont tout
à fait conscients je dirais du travail
du rôle et de l'accompagnement du
Conseil qu'ils doivent avoir et
accompagner les acquéreurs et leurs
prodiguer les conseils nous allons
proposer prochainement
un contrat nouveau d'ailleurs qui existe
déjà juridiquement je l'ai évoqué auprès
de Monsieur le Directeur des Affaires
civil du saut lors d'un entretien il y a
15 jours lequel a accueilli
favorablement cette disposition en mode
disant c'est une excellente idée pour
accompagner la stratégie et pouvoirs
publics ce contrat est issu de la vente
d'immeuble à rénover ce qu'on appelle la
Vire et notamment quand nous avons
baptisé la vente en état futur de
rénovation énergétique c'est tout
simplement la possibilité pour un
propriétaire de choisir au moment de la
mutation quand il veut vendre le vin le
bien à ce moment là c'est de le vendre
avec les travaux ou de les vendre sans
des travaux mais on a un référent et on
a une valeur effectivement
d'étalonnements qui nous permet de voir
clair dans cet environnement des
mutations et savoir quelle est la valeur
effective de ce bien c'est un double
avantage c'est de permettre dans tous
les cas d'accompagner le vendeur sur
cette stratégie compte tenu
qu'aujourd'hui
la préoccupation de beaucoup de vendeurs
et d'acquéreurs c'est notamment ce
classement énergétique hier si c'était
le balcon ou la vue sur la campagne
aujourd'hui classement énergétique
devient des critères particuliers à des
critères principaux pour un acquéreur
donc il faut trouver un dispositif je
dirais visant à rassurer et visant
accompagné l'acquéreur dans ce cadre-là
la vente en état futur de rénovation a
lieu avec les travaux inclus avec une
garantie d'exécution et avec une
exécution avant ou postérieurement à
mutation avec une consigne qui signation
du prix une garantie bancaire voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire ce beaucoup de
choses ont été dites par l'ensemble de
de mes collègues
nous sommes bien conscients je dirais de
l'ensemble des obligations qui vont être
les nôtres dans le cadre des années à
venir je dirais tous les professionnels
de l'immobilier sont des alliés de la
rénovation énergétique je reprends et
j'ai entendu je ne sais plus avec mes
confrères a dit hier oui moi aussi ça
m'a choqué je crois que c'est Étienne
qui a dit à aucun moment on a entendu le
nom syndic de copropriété on a parlé de
tout le monde
des de tous les intervenants les promo
les constructeurs les architectes les
aménageurs on n'a pas un moment
seulement un moment on a prononcé le nom
de syndic de copropriété les syndics
vont être les grands artisans de la
rénovation énergétique et on a besoin
bien évidemment de cette reconnaissance
qui doit être la nôtre parce que nous
sommes je dirais la cheville ouvrière de
ce dispositif et l'ensemble des
syndicats et tous les professionnels
sont résolument déterminés accompagner
les politiques publiques mais je crois
que nous avons besoin je lui permet de
le dire d'un peu plus de considération
quand nous faisons des propositions pour
lesquelles nous n'avons pas de réponse
et parfois une forme de mépris nous
sommes des acteurs du logement nous
sommes peut-être des agitateurs d'idées
mais c'est je dirais afin de répondre et
à la naissance du bien public
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci aux uns et aux autres donc sans
plus tarder parce qu'on a encore une
petite demi-heure pour échanger avant
que nous accueillons la ministre je
laisse la parole à notre rapporteur
[Musique]
nous a montré toutes les problématiques
qu'on pouvait avoir et puis ensuite on a
tout ce qui peut être bailleurs sociaux
logements sociaux sur lequel c'est une
autre manière d'intervenir je dirais que
peut-être pour le coup plus simple parce
que elle est peut-être plus financière
en tout cas et en tout cas en terme
technique elle est peut-être plus simple
sur sur les copropriétés c'est vrai que
moi j'ai beaucoup entendu enfin la
problématique des PE alors après sans
rentrer dans le détail du DPE de savoir
si les filles a pas fiables etc c'est
vrai qu'on a on a reçu on a eu beaucoup
d'auditions sur ce sur ce sujet là on
entend aussi le fait de ne pas revenir
en arrière en tout cas de ne pas changer
les règles et donc je pense que voilà on
est peut-être plutôt sur sur quelque
chose de se dire comment comment le
fiabilise en tout cas mais voilà on a
cet outil là qui a parlé de thermomètre
en tout cas il faut peut-être fiabiliser
le thermomètre mais il faut il faut
certainement le le conserver après il y
a la question c'est comment ce DPE
justement on le on applique sur sur les
copropriétés et vous avez beaucoup parlé
justement la difficulté d'avoir ce DPU à
titre individuel enfin en tout cas par
logement
et c'est vrai que le DPE collectif
paraît plutôt une idée intéressante donc
bon vous l'avez déjà déjà répondu mais
voilà moi c'est vrai que la question
qu'on a déjà pu se poser c'est cette
proposition justement peut-être d'avoir
un DPE collectif qui permettrait déjà
d'avoir cette cette orientation et qui
permettrait de d'avoir ces travaux dans
son dans l'ensemble
ce qui empêche pas d'ailleurs d'avoir
des ppm individuels mais en tout cas
d'avoir le DPE collectif qui soit lui
seul opposable en tout cas ça me
paraissait en tout cas un moyen assez
efficace pour les pour les collectifs
pour les copropriétés de pouvoir de
pouvoir avancer et de et de ne pas être
dans les différentes problématiques que
vous avez pu décrire ou qu'on avait pu
qu'on avait pu voir donc du coup voilà
enfin si vous avez quelques éléments
supplémentaires là-dessus ça me ça
m'intéresse j'avais un autre un autre
élément vous en avez pas beaucoup parlé
c'est vrai que sur le parcours alors
c'est vrai que avec les syndics de
copropriété il y a un accompagnement et
c'est votre métier donc je dirais qu'on
a le l'expertise mais c'est vrai qu'on
voit aussi que vous l'avez dit entre 16
19 types de d'aide différentes donc on
est dans un maquille assez assez
complexe
on a quand même des organisations au
niveau local et qui peuvent être très
différentes d'ailleurs suivant les
suivant les collectivités mais on a pu
voir
dans nos déplacements et puis dans les
différentes auditions que quand on avait
soit une agence locale de l'énergie soit
une plateforme de rénovation thermique
et notamment qui avait mis des
dispositifs envers les copropriétés
et un accompagnement on avait plutôt
quelque chose qui fonctionnait en tout
cas qui avait cette accompagnement là
qui avait justement cette cette porte
d'entrée en tout cas et
des dispositifs du coup qui étaient
aussi à travailler avec les copropriétés
pour pouvoir avancer sur cette
rénovation
donc je voulais savoir si vous aviez des
on est allé en déplacement sur l'Isère
et donc sur la métropole de Grenoble
avec parental dispositif murmure
justement qui est vraiment lié aux
propriétés savoir si vous aviez d'autres
exemples en tout cas si ça vous
paraissait pertinent en tout cas d'avoir
cet échelon local et ce lien direct au
niveau des collectivités et d'avoir
peut-être cette porte d'entrée locale
qui permettait aussi d'avoir une
spécificité en suivant les territoires
et puis une dernière question qui était
peut-être plus sur on a parlé de la
deuxième vie des bâtiments c'est vrai
que sur toutes les dispositifs qu'on
peut voir dispositif cœur de ville etc
on voit qu'on se confronte à souvent des
vrais problématiques sur comment comment
tout simplement isoler quoi enfin
comment faire ses travaux là sur
l'isolation par l'extérieur qui est très
compliqué et donc du coup des fois des
interventions qui restent très limitées
à moins justement d'avoir des opérations
qui soient beaucoup plus importantes et
qui soit dans voilà de rénovation
globale quoi donc pareil savoir si vous
aviez des des informations enfin en tout
cas des exemples en tout cas qui
capillent de programme qui puissent se
faire à ce titre à ce titre là voilà
merci alors pour réponse première
question monsieur Lagarde vous avez
souhaité commencer oui merci donc je
suis également au Césaire des Pays de la
Loire on a fait un rapport sur le
tercélaire et justement l'évolution des
bâtiments pour qu'ils aient des cycles
de vie différents passer des bitations à
bureau commerce etc et que les
architectes travaillent là dessus et
l'intégrer dès à présent évidemment et
dans les transformations qui ont été
évoquées c'est fondamental d'autant plus
que vous êtes pas sans savoir qu'on est
en pleine crise du logement ça fait plus
de six mois que j'allais être en tout
cas dans notre région qui se porte mieux
sur le plan du logement relativement
l'État les représentants de l'État sur
le fait qu'il faut faire un plan
Marshall c'est-à-dire on en est pas
discuté il faut qu'on prenne des
décisions rapidement sans perdre de vue
ce que l'ADEME répète
c'était de ma mère j'ai un bien en
Italie et au moment de la signature
devant le notaire il m'a dit mais est-ce
que les bénéficier du 110%
j'en ai parlé à des délégués
interministériel il y a 2 ans
c'est quelque chose qui marche en Italie
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des ensembliers
ceux qu'on a déjà évoqué des ensembliers
qui prennent tout en main y compris
l'accompagnement bancaire les 10% c'est
pour la banque c'est pour simplifier le
reste c'est l'entreprise qui gère
l'ensemble des travaux qui accompagne ce
qui est efficace et ça va jusqu'au bout
mon état italien actuellement ils ont
tout dépensé ils ont tout dépensé tout
ce que vous avez comme argent ils ont
mis 94 milliards de mémoire pardonnerai
des erreurs de chiffres pour rénover 3%
des logements ça vous donne l'ordre de
grandeur de ceux qui va nous attendre
moi j'ai annoncé depuis le début dans
mon instance que ça coûterait ce plan
Marshall 2000 milliards
la réalité la réalité c'est à dire des
monogestes digeste etc de revenir etc à
la fin infini 2000 milliards voilà c'est
tout ce que je voulais dire et je vous
remercie évidemment de nous avoir invité
et de partager avec nous ce est
excellent moment alors qu'il souhaite
par rapport aux questions du rapporteur
à la fois sur le DPE collectif enfin
réagir oui madame modifié
merci non moi je voulais juste revenir
sur le dispositif cœur de ville et en
effet
j'ai oublié de parler d'un sujet qui me
paraît extrêmement important qu'elle
assurait l'évasion on en a un petit peu
abordé via le neuf mais en fait on le
fait dans l'ancien la Suarez l'élévation
c'est juste l'outil magique pour
pour répondre à une problématique de
rénovation globale des immeubles
l'avantage c'est qu'aujourd'hui nos
copropriétaires ne savent pas vraiment
qu'ils ont un foncier aérien qui a une
valeur et en fait cette valeur
lorsqu'elle est vendue même bébé bien
évidemment elle génère du cash qui
permet de financer la rénovation
énergétique
on pensait la difficulté c'est pas tant
les copropriétaires je vous le dis parce
qu'en fait il voit vite l'intérêt et on
pensait que les copropriétaires du
dernier étage seraient assez réticents
on pensait que avoir des travaux en
milieu habité c'était compliqué pas
vraiment
on fait voter des
surélévation
on est très bien vu des collectivités
bien évidemment et en plus on n'a pas de
problématique de stationnement
complémentaire en fait on choisit nos
immeubles en fonction de la proximité
des transports
la difficulté bien évidemment elle
réside dans la capacité de trouver des
acteurs sur le marché c'est un métier de
nouveau pour construire très vite aller
plus vite possible en milieu ABT léger
en hauteur d'accord ça c'est un
véritable un véritable savoir-faire et
si on parle de la problématique de la
rénovation énergétique là on est coeur
de ville mais va arriver le problème
majeur on est présent dans les stations
de ski à des passoires thermiques dans
toutes les stations donc en majorité à
70% des immeubles on est F et G et donc
c'est des on a un boulevard pour
l'assurer l'élévation donc voilà c'est
intégré dans le dans le raisonnement
parce que ça plaît c'est pas compl
commence à mettre en oeuvre c'est un
petit temps long parce que bah on rentre
dans la rénovation il faut faire voter
mais en tout cas c'est quelque chose
qu'on sait faire et on est en train de
le tester en ville Paris 15e et en
station à Villard-de-Lans on pourra vous
faire un rapport après mais en tout cas
les retours sont déjà favorables merci
Madame battle oui pour compléter les
propos de Karine et je souscris
totalement à ses propos il nous
semblerait intéressant lors du DPE et du
PPP du 3pp
d'inclure d'élargir
les travaux réalisés dans ce cadre là
d'une part un scénario qui génère 35%
d'économie d'énergie d'autre part
intégrer systématiquement au regard de
ce que permet le PLU le scénario de la
surévélation qui permet effectivement de
financer la rénovation énergétique par
par cette surévélation donc c'est je
souscris totalement à propos de de
Karine et je voulais revenir sur le rôle
de mon accompagnateur Reno ou de la MO
que vous avez le rapporteur aujourd'hui
une rénovation globale en copropriété
encore une fois je sais pas combien tu
en as Karine moi j'en ai 210 tu dois en
avoir
voilà donc on a on a systématiquement le
syndic systématiquement s'appuie sur un
amo et cet amo est là pour aller
travailler les subventions la recherche
des subventions que ce soit des
subventions nationales ou des
subventions locales et cette amo est là
aussi pour travailler le financement
donc ça existe déjà il y a déjà ce rôle
complet qui qui fonctionne et qui
fonctionne bien donc je en tout cas en
tant que practicienne de la de la de la
rénovation il ne nous semble pas
utile de rajouter ou de complexifier ce
rôle là il existe il fonctionne et il
fonctionne bien
de la compagnateur Renov puisque en tant
que ancien membre du conseil
d'administration de Lana on s'est rendu
compte que la plupart de ces
accompagnateurs quand on a commencé les
formations ne connaissez pas du tout la
copropriété ce sont des anciens de des
alecques ou de l'ADEM et on s'est
rencontrés on s'est retrouvé face à on
va dire une porte de prison je suis
désolé de le dire il a fallu intervenir
sur des formations les premières
formations les a faites avec Lana
première formation on a eu 250 personnes
sur les 250 il y en avait 10 qui avait
déjà traité de la covid et les autres ne
connaissaient pas et on a commencé au
mois de mars de l'an dernier donc ça
fait un an aujourd'hui on se rend compte
que les accompagnateurs rénovent monte
en puissance mais ni sont pas donc quand
on compare ce qui s'est fait avec
l'agence parisienne du climat étant
parisien on a globalement en moyenne sur
ces accompagnateurs rénov 4 à 5 ans de
retard je suis désolé de le dire il ne
comprennent pas l'agenda de copropriété
les décisions en assemblée générale
pourquoi c'est pas fait pourquoi c'est
pas tout de suite c'est voter mais
passer l'ordre de service je réponds
mais non il y a toujours ces temps de
co-propriété qu'il faut connaître et
pour lequel effectivement pour eux
c'était de la maison individuelle et
tout va vite donc attention oui il en
faut oui oui c'est nécessaire oui il
faut les former comme on était formés
tous nos gestionnaires de covoyés qui
comprennent ces différents points parce
qu'on leur a expliqué comment ça
marchait comment il fallait chercher les
subventions mais tout ceci se fait pas
en 3 minutes et là on nous a dit il y a
aucun problème vous aurez 2000
accompagnateurs rénov c'est très bien
ils sont charmants mais à en formation
on y était pas
oui
comme je suis assisté c'est remarquable
et merci Pierre je me permettais de
revenir sur les les diagnostics
individuels et collectifs donc la
problématique on l'a évoqué mais je me
permets quand même d'aller un petit peu
dans le détail avec des cas pas
technique pratico pratique
moi j'ai des immeubles et je pense que
je vois pas être le seul des immeubles
qui sont classés on va dire FSG en tout
cas c'est cela que nous visons et nous
devons faire porter au vote le fait de
d'investir lourdement des travaux
collectifs
forcément lors des assemblées générales
on va leur promettre une amélioration
énergétique de leur appartement
individuel mais si vous êtes
propriétaire d'un appartement au
deuxième étage d'un immeuble de six
étages placer plein sud et en plus qui
n'est pas un T1 vous avez beaucoup plus
de chance de vous retrouver à une
notation qui vous permettra soit de
louer à terme soit devant avec une
décote faible voire une surcote alors
que si vous êtes au rez-de-chaussée
plein nord avec une petite typologie
c'est en gros globalement perdu d'avance
bon donc on le sait tous mais c'est un
problème très lourd parce que le
copropriétaire planeur va contribuer aux
travaux sur le plan financier autant que
celui qui est situé plein sud
gagner une note énergétique F et G a du
B ou voire du C c'est un score enfin
faut je pense pas que pour l'instant
sache encore le faire
la proposition qui est que nous faisons
c'est de dire il faut intégrer les deux
diagnostics et monsieur le rapporteur
vous m'avait tendu la perche
c'est-à-dire que je pense
qu'effectivement le diagnostic collectif
doit être valorisé voire reconnue
doit-il être opposable c'est encore un
sujet mais en tout cas doit être intégré
comme un indicateur
permettant de louer ou de ne pas louer
souvent ce qui nous a été reporté
c'était oui mais l'acquéreur d'un
appartement doit connaître la
consommation de son appartement rien
n'empêche de mettre également le
diagnostic individuel pour qu'il sache
que son appartement en place et plein
nord sera de toute façon plus
consommateur que celui plein sud les
diagnostics collectifs doivent prendre
le dessus à mon avis parce qu'on va pas
y arriver sinon et pire si on y arrive
je pense qu'on va mentir aux
copropriétaires on leur promettant une
amélioration énergétique qui de toute
façon sera décevante
voilà et celui qui est planeur il
changera pas sa situation géographique
c'est-à-dire qu'il est plein nord il
vendra de toute façon plein nord donc
dans le prix la décote sera sur le
diagnostic individuel mais dans son
interdiction de louer on dira vous avez
collectivement fait un effort et donc
vous avez quand même le droit de louer
mais le locataire c'est qu'il a un
logement voilà je pense que ce sujet là
si on si on aborde pas maintenant on va
le on va le traîner très longtemps ça va
être des conflits de d'acquéreurs de
vendeurs surtout je vous rappelle le
diagnostic est opposable donc voilà je
pense que ce sujet là on doit le traiter
d'ores et des gens en y mettant les deux
diagnostics
merci
quelque chose dont on n'a pas parlé
je dirais c'est
donc c'est un programme ambitieux on va
devoir faire face à d'importants travaux
et il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui dans le
cas de lisibilité ma prime rénove seul
les entreprises disposant d'une
qualification RGE peuvent prétendre à
accompagner les propriétaires il est
copropriétaires
c'est quelque chose qui a été quantifié
qui est un chiffre je crois Bruno Le
Maire la évoqué réelle au mois de
novembre 2022 16% des entreprises des
700 000 entreprises on dispose de cette
qualification et son nom est en
diminution
et
Bruno Le Maire lui-même précisait qu'il
fallait multiplier ce chiffre par 4 pour
répondre à l'ambition de ces travaux
mais je pense que même ce nombre est
insuffisant pourquoi
on le sait tous dans nos immeubles les
immeubles que nous gérons nous sommes
toujours à flux tendu sur des corps de
métiers qui sont rares je pense aux
zingueurs je pense au couvreur je pense
je chauffagiste électricien on a on a
des difficultés même assuré des fois je
dirais l'entretien curatif de nos
immeubles et je parle pas de l'entretien
préventif
aujourd'hui on va rajouter donc des
couches de travaux complémentaires dans
le cas de ce plan de rénovation
j'aimerais qu'on ait une approche je
dirais chiffré de l'importance des
travaux de l'énergétique travaux de
rénovation énergétique et les rapporter
notamment en chiffre d'affaires du
bâtiment existant aujourd'hui et on se
rendra vie compte que vite compte que
nous sommes en sous-effectif et de façon
très très importante donc je crois que
on parlait d'un plan Marshall tout à
l'heure oui c'est vrai il faut un plan
Marshall et de la formation si on veut
gagner ce défi de la rénovation
énergétique il faut adapter les
capacités je dirais des entreprises du
bâtiment et qualifiées pour réaliser ses
travaux je dirais à la situation à
laquelle on va être confronté on ne peut
pas être aujourd'hui dans je dirais un
système où les entreprises restent de
plus en plus rares et on sait ce que ça
se traduit en terme d'économie dans
l'économie générale il faut au contraire
équilibre et accompagner l'ensemble de
ces immeubles donc il y a un plan
Marshall important à la fois sur la
formation et la création d'entreprise
vous savez j'ai toujours entendu moi les
politiques que les politiques l'occasion
grande campagne dire que la rénovation
est énergétique et l'écologie c'est un
gisement d'emploi nous avons une
opportunité historique maintenant pour
le démontrer bien il va falloir faire
une transformation notamment de ce que
nous avons dit ce que nous avons entendu
je crois parce que nous en avons besoin
de ces entreprises donc il faut un plan
Marshall de la création de bâtiment pour
avoir les entreprises dont nous allons
avoir besoin de se poser monsieur vital
voulait prendre la parole oui c'est en
complément pour la question de monsieur
le rapporteur sur les zones on pouvait
aussi faire de la rénovation complète
comme je le disais tout à l'heure la
rénovation complète nécessite du coup un
coup d'achat des bâtiments élevés un
coût de rénovation assez élevé un des
sujets qu'on pourrait pousser c'est lié
au territoire où on produit ces
logements réhabilités qui nécessitent
une fiscalité qui est souvent celle du
Malraux qui est souvent poussée pour
faire les opérations donc vous pouvez
voir une question de zonage ou est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce que c'est PSMV donc
les quartiers sur lesquels on produit du
logement Malraux est-ce qu'ils sont
toujours adaptés ils ont été élaborés il
y a fort longtemps donc est-ce qu'il y a
pas besoin de les sentir et de les
retravailler on a vu que les zonages
actions coeur de ville n'ont pas pour
l'instant porté leurs fruits puisqu'on a
eu très peu de production en de
Normandie donc peut-être plus
capitaliser sur le Malraux sur des
zonages à définir et après peut-être
Franck avait un complément sur un autre
aspect
en complément sur le Malraux c'est aussi
travailler sur la possibilité des
extensions un certain nombre de pays
européens dont la Grèce compte pas la
cité autorise la surélévation ou
l'extension sur des bâtiments monument
historiques pour éviter qu'il faisait
l'arbre et qu'au contraire il soit à
nouveau vivant plutôt que
que que stopper dans leur évolution donc
on a un double travail sur le Malraux
c'est l'élargissement des usages
c'est-à-dire ne pas s'arrêter qu'à
l'usage pur d'un seul usage logement
parce qu'on a souvent des typologies
d'actifs dans lequel on va installer un
commerce des activités des activités
tertiaires au sens large donc élargir le
champ du mal élargir son zonage et aussi
on élargir la capacité de faire des
extensions des surélévation qui
s'appliquent aussi bien dans les
rénovations globales que dans les
rénovations en milieu occupés telles que
l'évoquer nos collègues sur les
copropriétés aujourd'hui vous disiez
c'est vous avez des exemples qui
fonctionnent sur les surélévation j'en
suis fort heureux mais nous on est au
contraire énormément d'exemples où nous
sommes bloqués par un PLU qui nous
interdit par l'incapacité à pouvoir le
faire pour des raisons ensuite de de
d'AVF absolument où on a des blocages
sur les hauteurs libres et la
possibilité de faire on veut revitaliser
comment dirais les villes moyennes et le
périurbain nous avions émis un rapport
avec le Plan Bâtiment Durable et la rixe
qui sont les évaluateurs immobiliers en
France en 2020 pour pour que nous avions
le premier madame wargon vous retrouvez
déjà toutes ces propositions vous les
transmettra c'est extrêmement important
de permettre de retrouver une agilité
dans l'acte de relancer l'activité de la
rénovation tant en milieu occupé que en
capacité de retravailler de l'existant
qui est vide ou en cours de délabrement
et on a aussi des propositions qui
peuvent vous paraître surprenantes de
type remembrement comme cela s'est passé
dans le milieu agricole dans les années
60 vous avez un certain nombre de
propriétaires dans les petites villes
qui sont propriétaires de plusieurs
appartements dans plusieurs immeubles il
y a un moment faut se poser la question
du remembrement pour pouvoir agir sur
les immeubles complets pour voir rénover
des immeubles complets retrouver des
respirations dans ces villes et ces
centres-villes changer les affectations
vous avez le cas par exemple
d'affectation les logements étaient
uniquement dans les premiers niveaux les
gens recherchent de la lumière voulant
mettez les logements au quatrième et
cinquième niveau donc il faut faire des
extensions rendre les terrasses
accessible surtout dans le Sud de la
France ce qui n'était pas le cas sur un
toit avec des tuilerons une fois vous
voyez tous les enjeux que ça implique et
si on essaye de tout légiférer on y
arrive pas donc il faut bien que nous
ayons une législation cadre qui pousse à
la réglementation et qui en fait demande
uniquement au maire de justifier son
opposition et non pas comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des cas où
c'est le maire qui doit avec son conseil
municipal prendre la décision et voter
la modification de pluie et dérogation
ça on nourrit effectivement énormément
de conseils tant mieux pour eux et on
les adore pour travailler sur des
dérogations qui si elles étaient de
faites seraient sans doute beaucoup plus
simple pour nous tous de travailler sur
la capacité de d'exploiter au maximum
les plans locaux d'urbanisme travailler
sur les extensions travailler sur la
rénovation globale avec des performances
dans lesquelles on peut s'engager je
voulais citer tout à l'heure sur le BBC
rénovation
donc on est on a les moyens mais on est
souvent bloqué par des articles de loi
ou des décrets qui redonnent la
possibilité d'être bloqué par des
acteurs administratifs ou parce que
parfois non sachant dans laquelle dans
ces évolutions là puis dernier point je
voulais l'évoquer la Commission
européenne permet dans ces évolutions
sur la TVA de proposer une TVA à taux
réduit à 10% sur les travaux de
rénovation énergétique pourquoi la
France ne s'en empare pas
vaste sujet sur la TVA il y avait
monsieur Frémont derrière vous oui
pour reprendre précisément certaines de
vos questions qui qui sont dans votre
questionnaire relative au copropriété à
la question 10 s'est-il souhaitable
d'adapter le calendrier des
interdictions de passoire énergétiques
prévues par la loi climat pour les
copropriétés
adapté oui en tout cas prévoir peut-être
des dérogations si le syndicat des
copropriétaires donne des gages on
craint un très fort contentieux qui va
opposer les bailleurs les
copropriétaires bailleurs au syndicat
des copropriétaires puisque si le
copropriétaire bailleur arrive à
démontrer qu'il a fait le maximum de
travaux chez lui pour s'isoler avec
malgré tout ça notre sdradée et que de
ce fait il est interdit de louer il
risque de il risque il va se je crois
qu'on a déjà un cas une assignation il
va se retourner contre le syndicat des
copropriétaires pour le préjudice subi
c'est-à-dire la perte de son loyer et il
va tout simplement demander la
copropriété de lui payer son loyer donc
il me semble
pertinent de prévoir une dérogation pour
le l'interdiction de louer si le
bailleur démonte que la copropriété a
voté en assemblée générale un plan et
que lui-même a voté favorablement à ce
plan est-il souhaitable et possible
d'accélérer ça c'est la question 12 la
prise de décision en copropriété
concernant la rénovation énergétique en
augmentant la fréquence des assemblées
générales ça me semble pas nécessaire
puisqu'il est tout à fait possible et
assez facile de réunir des assemblées
générales extraordinaires entre deux
assemblées générales annuelles donc qui
ne sont pas nécessaires de modifier
encore une fois la loi de 65 en tout cas
à ce niveau là
et la question
16 le calendrier mis en place par la loi
climat et résilience pour la rénovation
des copropriétés donc des TG PPP vous
paraît-il à latte on a beaucoup de
calendriers aujourd'hui on a le
calendrier des interdictions de louer on
a le calendrier des plans pluriel de
travaux qui diffèrent lui-même en
fonction de la taille de l'immeuble plus
de 200 lots entre 2,50 et 200 lots moins
de 50 lots donc on s'y perd dans les
calendriers on a le calendrier des du
DPE collectif qui lui-même différents du
calendrier des PPP et on a le calendrier
tout simplement des entreprises et de
leur carnet de commandes de leur guide
de leur disponibilité et le calendrier
de l'assemblée générale qui est de la
copropriété qui lui-même le temps long
puisque les décisions doivent mûrir on
est dans des mini démocraties comme vous
le savez alors est-il trop tard pour
harmoniser tous ces calendriers je le
disais tout à l'heure nous en avons
assez de la fluctuation des lois donc la
question je pose la question ici est-ce
que il aime pas trop tard pour
harmoniser je n'ai pas vraiment la
réponse et je j'insiste et je reviens
sur la question 19 les obstacles à
l'emprunt collectif je l'ai évoqué
nous sommes nécessaires de modifier de
simplifier simplifier l'article 26-4
pour ne laisser plus qu'un seul prêt
collectif me permet ici d'insister le
vrai prêt collectif accordé au syndicats
des copropriétaires auxquels tous les
copropriétaires seront obligatoires
adhérents si j'ai envie de dire mais ils
paieront le remboursement du prêt au
titre de leur charge et au lieu d'avoir
quatre appels de fonds travaux ils
auront 50 appels pour rembourser
l'échéancier ça on sait parfaitement
faire on observera je pense lorsqu'on
aura très collectif bancaire simple de
nouveaux acteurs bancaires qui
arriveront peut-être sur le marché
puisque aujourd'hui le prêt copro 100
qui est un faux prêt collectif un prêt
multi individuel est un état une sorte
d'ovni pour les banques elle ne
comprennent pas finalement elle ne
savent pas vraiment qui sera
l'emprunteur final donc elle demande
tout un tas de pièces de documents de
dossiers et qui se transforme en usine à
gaz pour le gestionnaire je le disais
tout à l'heure moi-même je n'ose même
plus proposer des c'est faux pré
collectifs donc le vrai prêt collectif
mais évidemment le faire voter non plus
à l'unanimité bien sûr mais à la même
majorité que ce vote les travaux sinon
c'est impossible d'obtenir l'unanimité
dans une copropriété vous le savez bien
et tout dernier mot je reviens dessus la
surélévation effectivement est une bonne
solution j'ai moi-même rendez-vous en
fin de semaine avec un
opérateur architecte qui s'est
spécialisé dans la rénovation dans la
surélévation
on verra qu'elles sont les immeubles qui
sont
possiblesment techniques pour faire
cette surélévation mais en tout cas
c'est quelque chose qui je pense marche
il est vrai que la loi allure a facilité
la surélévation en réduisant la règle de
majorité de l'article 26 à l'article 25
pour les zones où on a les secteurs où
on a un droit de préemption en
supprimant le droit de veto du dernier
étage du propriétaire du dernier étage
pour le transformer en droit de
préférence c'était une bonne chose et en
supprimant le COS évidemment ça a permis
de libérer du foncier donc ça je pense
qu'il faut également insister dans cette
voie qui me semble tout à fait saine et
faisable
alors je crois que Monsieur Quentin
voulait encore réagir je voulais faire
une dernière intervention notamment
parce qu'on parle de rénovation
énergétique ça concerne pas que les
parcs des copropriétés quand on a fait
on a fait une représentation des
logements classés f et g à partir dans
des diagnostics qui ont été données et
on s'est rendu compte on a superposé
deux cas à la fois les logements classés
F et G et les logements vacants et on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y a une
parfaite concordance je dirais dans une
diagonale de ville de l'Est au sud-ouest
et notamment un patrimoine qui fait
l'objet de la vacance pour mémoire pour
rappeler que ce parc de logement vacants
a grandi de 1 million de logements en 15
ans et ses logements sont laissés de
côté ce sont des logements qui font
partie du territoire national qui font
partie de notre richesse aussi et ce
sont des logements abandonnés pour
lesquels les familles n'ont plus les
moyens et je rebondis sur les annonces
du CNR qui notamment prévoit que le prêt
à T0 sera seulement accessible pour la
rénovation des appartements dans les
zones tendues en collectif et on a exclu
les maisons individuelles et tout ce
moins d'écarter de ce dispositif c'est
une grave erreur et quand on veut faire
de la rénovation énergétique et bien on
se penche sur le patrimoine auquel
veulent avoir accès à des ménages futurs
et primo-accédant en propriété donc la
rénovation aussi participe de ce soutien
et notamment au maintien de la
valorisation de ce patrimoine qui est
oublié dans des territoires qui sont
aussi oubliés et la rénovation
énergétique c'est pas uniquement les
grandes agglomérations deuxième chose je
voudrais faire une observation sur une
question qui a été posée à Olivier Klein
lors d'une réunion plénière 40 personnes
sur le site de la GHP figure une réponse
selon laquelle l'indécence énergétique
trouve à s'appliquer notamment non pas
au 1er janvier 2025
pour les appartements classésg mais au
renouvellement du bail je m'explique un
propriétaire bailleur aujourd'hui qui
conclut un bail de 3 ans avec un bail
prenant effet au 1er juillet 2023
se retrouve dans tous les cas exposé au
1er janvier 2025 à avoir un logement
indécent il est bien dit qu'un logement
classé G est indécent au 1er janvier
sur le site de LGP on dit non non il est
pas indécent il sera indécent au 1er
juillet 2020 2026
ça c'est la réponse du ministère nous ne
connaissez pas la connaissons pas la
position du juge judiciaire et là ça
fait courir un gros risque un nombre de
professionnels d'amener des
propriétaires aujourd'hui à conclure des
bots de 3 ans et avoir une période
intermédiaire où ils vont être exposés
au 1er janvier 2025 avec un recours
possible du locataire à l'encontre du
propriétaire nous voulons une réponse
précise et nous ne l'avons pas et
personne ne la prend donc vous voyez
c'est un contexte il faut mesurer toutes
les conséquences d'un tel dispositif
nous nous sommes professionnels on doit
accompagner nos propriétaires mais les
interrogations et les questions qui nous
sommes posées au quotidien nous mettent
dans une situation très embarrassante et
nous n'avons pas certainement pas voir
notre responsabilité professionnelle
engagée sur un manquement à cette
réponse
je pense qu'il faut qu'on voilà on va
terminer c'est pile poil 16h je suis
désolé parce que c'était passionnant et
certainement vous arrivez encore bon
nombre de choses à nous dire on nous
signale que madame la ministre vient
d'arriver donc je vous remercie si vous
souhaitez par rapport aux questionnaire
voilà nous faire passer quelques
compléments d'informations vous le
faites passer assez rapidement puisque
on envisage de rendre notre rapport à la
fin du mois de juin et publiquement
première semaine de juillet on vous
remercie très sincèrement et on sait
pouvoir compter sur votre mobilisation
pour relever ce défi de la rénovation
énergétique merci à vous tous
merci